l'industrie du recyclage est en crise au
québec l'entreprise rebuts solides
canadiens qui exploite quatre centres de
tri de à montréal à châteauguay et à un
saguenay a l'intention de mettre fin à
ses activités à court terme
les villes concernées ne veulent pas
mettre plus d'argent dans ce service
mais le gouvernement du québec pourrait
apporter une aide financière
l'entreprise explique qu'elle subit
d'importantes pertes financières en
raison de l'effondrement du marché
mondial du papier recyclé avec nous ce
soir marc olivier professeur chercheur
au centre de transfert technologique en
écologie industrielle de l'université de
sherbrooke monsieur olivier bonsoir
viennent le soir
alors expliquez nous un petit peu ce
groupe qu'on appelle tiru ou rebuts
solides canadiens qui annonce cette
semaine son intention de mettre fin à
ses activités associées à ces quatre
centres de tri au québec comment on en
arrive là
mais cette entreprise c'est déjà une
entreprise à ses anciennes qui trouve sa
source en france
ils sont spécialisés dans toutes sortes
de gestion de projet en assainissement
des gestions aussi de stations
d'assainissement des eaux usées tout ça
quand ils sont établis si peu à peu ils
sont acoquinés ils ont été dans avec
donc absorbé par le groupe
robichaud des canadiens pour rendre
service mais pourquoi on allait là c'est
seulement parce que hein on a comme
petit problème d'avoir de très vieux
centre de tri au québec qui sont en
déficit de modernisation qui ne peuvent
pas traiter facilement toutes les
matières que l'on voudrait recyclé donc
le terry qui se fait est souvent un tri
de peau très bonne qualité
vous avez vu que on se fait bloquer la
mise en mise en marché d'un certain
nombre de ces ballots de matière on
n'est plus capable de les expédier en
amérique du nord parce que ya très peu
d'entreprises amérique du nord qui
acceptent d'acheter nos matières elles
ne sont pas bien très bien trier et même
la chine et l'inde ont resserré leurs
critères importations de nos résidus de
nos résidus mais en même temps des
résidus de tous les pays industralisés
possédant les nôtres ya véritablement un
effondrement de la demande si les
bateaux ne sont pas bien trier si les
badauds sont bien trier la demande est
toujours là alors présentement on est
un point de non retour quand va-t-on se
décider à faire un très grande
correction dans la qualité du tri de nos
centres de tri lorsqu'ils sont trop
vieux lorsqu'ils sont vieillissants
est-ce qu'on a perdu le contrôle dans la
qualité du tri je pense qu'on a perdu le
contrôle dans la qualité du tri on a vu
des saints malheureuse se déroule
effectivement dans les centres de tri
pour ce qui est des résultats on tente
désespérément de corriger la situation
mais c'est rollin simplement pour le
papier j'ai l'impression que ça va
prendre deux ans avant qu'on puisse dire
que les quelque chose comme 23 centres
de tri qui sont en opération au québec
réussissent à améliorer suffisamment la
qualité du tri du papier pourquoi on
peut se repenser à réinvestir le marché
nord américain
aussi bien que le marché étranger
d'ailleurs et on se fait même renvoyer
des conteneurs de déchets au canada on
se demande d'ailleurs comment la
malaisie a pu faire ça retournez onze
conteneurs de déchets de la même façon
que les philippines ont pu le faire il
ya quelques années vous souvenez que les
philippines ont des clans déclaré la
guerre au canada pour que l'ambassadeur
canadien aux philippines acceptent de
reprendre 66 conteneurs qu'il ne voulait
plus avoir qui traînait sur leur qui
depuis des années et qui contenaient des
choses inavouables
oui on a investi dans les dernières
années il ya quand même de l'argent qui
était mis dans le cycle âge et on me
investi on a investi dans les centres de
tri on a investi dans la reconnaissance
des plats cités dans le tri des
plastiques
mais en même temps on n'a pas refait nos
chaînes de tri on a et on se retrouve
avec des chaînes de tri qui sont sous
dimensionnés pour la quantité de matière
que l'on voudrait trier donc on laisse
entrer les matières à toute vitesse et
ça donne un tri qui est pas très fameux
en bout de course
en plus de ça si vous avez vu des
saintes désolante
vous avez d accumulation énorme de
matière à trier que l'on laisse à
l'extérieur présentement se dégrader
sous la neige tout simplement parce
qu'on n'est plus capable de faire un tri
à la même vitesse ou les matières se
présente la ville de montréal dit
aujourd'hui on ne va pas fermer les
centres de tri l'entreprise veut s'en
aller mais on veut
les maintenir comment cela est possible
ben reprendre un exemple
sherbrooke sherbrooke a été confronté à
vos mains à la même situation il ya deux
l'opérateur privé de récup estrie donc
pour l'ensemble du centre de tri un
centre de tri âgées etc
du jour au lendemain le pour faire
pression
cet opérateur privé a dit moi je veux
dire que vous mmes aligner des millions
de plus et la façon de faire c'est je
commence à beaucoup moins bien trier je
laisse s'accumuler des matières à
l'extérieur soit que chabrol que réagit
différemment chaban qui ont dit si vous
ne remplissez pas les obligations de
votre compte or on vous excuse du centre
de tri ce qu'ils ont fait et ils ont
réembauché les salariés qui auparavant
étaient travaillés pour se priver
ils ont réorganisé la façon d'organiser
les horaires de tri et c'est maintenant
récupérer lui-même qui gère on peut le
personnel on peut faire ça ici écouter
ici notre langue et c'est une entreprise
est en défaut de rendre les services
contractuels et qu'elle doit rendre
jusqu à le signer des contrats
il faut bien qu'elle ait quelque chose
qui se passe c'est ce qu'on doit faire à
court terme et à long terme
à court terme qu'est ce qu'on doit faire
pour gérer ce alors à court terme n'est
certain que on ne veut pas un arrêt des
opérations parce que toute journée
d'arrêt des opérations vous nous créez
un problème extraordinaire et on le sait
ça va entraîner un gaspillage éhonté de
matières recyclables et on va retrouver
vers l'enfouissement mais c'est sûr et
on ne veut pas ça fait que ce une
opération à faire à très très très court
terme pour faire un continuum et à
l'intégration à long terme c'est la
finalité de ce que l'on veut faire est
ce que vous trouvez normal que on trie
des matières et que la meilleure façon
qu'on a présentement pour dire aux
citoyens nous sommes contents nous
voulons vous remercier de vingt années
de tri à la maison pour bien faire les
choses
est ce que vous trouvez normal que c'est
de créer de la valeur ajoutée en asie
maintenant il faut faire de l'économie
circulaire
il faut créer de la valeur ajoutée ici
sur le territoire avez vous entendu
parlé une seule fois les
ministères à vocation économique la
propos de l'économie circulaire à propos
du développement d'un marché pour être
capable d'utiliser les matières que l'on
ne triait ici de la promotion du
développement de pme
où sont les ministères à vocation
économique changement de philosophie que
ça prend ce sera exactement parfaite
mercredi on s'arrête ici merci beaucoup
pour ses explications ce soir